[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MANDEL: Hi, and
welcome to episode
number 109 of the weekly
Google Cloud Platform podcast.
I am Mark Mandel, and I'm here
with my colleague, Melanie
Warrick.
How are you doing
today, Melanie?
MELANIE WARRICK: Morning,
Mark, it's good to see you.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
bright and early.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Bright and early.
Just after MLK Day.
MARK MANDEL: Indeed.
We have some great
content this week.
You helped organize-- it's a
really cool episode, talking
about AutoML with Amy
Unruh and Sara Robinson.
MELANIE WARRICK: Right.
We are releasing the Cloud
AutoML Vision this week,
and so we wanted to get
them on the podcast,
because they both have been
working with the application
and they have some cool
examples that we're
going to put in our show notes.
But before we get
to the interview,
as always, we're going to
talk about the cool thing
of the week.
And stay tuned after
where we're going
to ask the question, if
you are with an educational
institution, how can you
get Google Cloud credits?
All right, first cool
thing of the week--
Google Brain actually
posted out a looking back
on 2017 and some really
top-of-mind interests for them.
And so AutoML is actually
one of the subjects
that's in their blog.
But they also touch on things
like speech understanding
and generation as well as TPUs,
and they give some great links
to different data
sources that you can
explore for machine learning.
So it's a good blog post
to check out and see
how they saw 2017.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
MELANIE WARRICK: Mark, you
got any other cool things
of the week?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, I'll
interrupt your ML fest.
MELANIE WARRICK: I know, it's
all about ML now, with me.
MARK MANDEL: It's
all about ML, I know.
No, that's good, I'll bring
it back to two of my passions,
actually.
So there is a new
solution that's
come out about running dedicated
game servers of multiplayer
games in Kubernetes Engine.
I know many people have
probably seen my blog post
series talking about doing
a very similar thing.
But there is now an
official solution
that has been released.
There's a blog post we'll
link in the show notes,
and the solution itself,
talking specifically
about how you can do this on
Kubernetes Engine on Google
Cloud Platform.
So if you're building
multiplayer games
and work in the games
industry, go have a look.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
And then the other
cool thing of the week
that we wanted to
mention is that Kaggle
has launched their data science
education resources and tools,
and I guess just actual
program, that's on their site.
We'll have a link on our
site as well, as always.
But this is being headed up by
Dan Becker and Rachael Tatman.
And they are covering subjects
like machine learning,
data visualization,
and deep learning.
And they're focusing most of
the course content in Python.
So you should check that out.
Couple other honorable mentions,
because we couldn't resist.
We heard about, apparently--
they've done all this
research in terms of trying
to map neurons in the brain.
A couple of years
back now, or I guess
I'm not sure actually
how long ago, they
were able to accomplish
this with a worm.
Well apparently,
recently, scientists
were able to take
what they've mapped
and put it into a Lego robot.
So we'll put a link to that.
It's got a video and
everything associated to it.
MARK MANDEL: It's really weird.
I'm watching this
video of the thing and,
like, there's a worm that's
making this thing move around?
MELANIE WARRICK: I know.
I know, it's kind of fun.
And then the other thing I
meant to mention with the Google
Brain look back--
they actually
referenced Kaz Sato,
who's one of our colleagues.
He did a rock-paper-scissors
example with TensorFlow.
And him and his son
apparently put this together,
and they actually
have some video
about how they make it
work, which is kind of fun.
So they play against this
tool that they built.
So we'll list that as well.
MARK MANDEL:
Awesome, sounds good.
MELANIE WARRICK: So now let's
go talk to Amy and Sara.
MARK MANDEL: Let's do that.
MELANIE WARRICK:
This week's podcast,
we are joined by two
of our colleagues, Sara
Robinson and Amy Unruh, who
are our developer relations
engineers.
Hi, good morning.
SARA ROBINSON: Morning.
MELANIE WARRICK: So can y'all
tell us a little bit more about
yourselves and what you do?
SARA ROBINSON: Sure.
Amy, you want to start?
AMY UNRUH: Sure, yeah.
I'm a developer relations
engineer for the Google Cloud
Platform, and I have a
background in AI and machine
learning, and focusing
on those areas right now.
In previous lives, I've
worked for startups
and done industrial
R&D, and even written
a book about App Engine.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
MELANIE WARRICK: Great.
Sara.
SARA ROBINSON: Awesome.
I'm on the same team as Amy.
We're focused on big data
and machine learning.
I come from more of a
self-taught background.
And before I was
on the Cloud team,
I was a developer relations
engineer on the Firebase team
at Google.
MELANIE WARRICK: Great.
So the reason why
we have both of you
here today is because today
we are releasing Cloud AutoML
Vision, and we wanted you both
to help share a little bit more
about what that's about.
So can you tell us what that is?
SARA ROBINSON: First I will talk
a little bit about the products
that we currently
have if you want
to do image recognition
on Google Cloud Platform.
So right now your options are
to use the Vision API, which
is a pre-trained
model, that gives you
access to this model with
just one REST API request.
So you can send your
image to the API.
You get back a bunch
of data on what it
thinks it's a picture of.
If you want to do
something more custom--
so the Vision API
doesn't require
any training data of your own.
If you have a problem that's
more specific to your use case,
you can build and train a
custom model with TensorFlow
and use your own training data
to train and tune the model.
But there's kind of been a
gap in our current product
offerings, and that's why we're
really excited about Cloud
AutoML Vision.
So what Cloud AutoML
Vision lets you do
is it lets developers that don't
have too much machine learning
expertise to build
high quality models.
So the way it works is
you upload your images--
they can be either a labeled
or unlabeled data set--
to the Cloud AutoML Vision UI.
You just press a button
to train your model.
And then you can
access your model
with an easy-to-use REST API.
AMY UNRUH: So under the
hood, it's using both
state-of-the-art
transfer learning,
and something called
neural architecture search.
Transfer learning-- essentially
what that is, is you
leverage an already
trained model.
It's already trained
[? weights. ?]
And it turns out that the
so-called embeddings that
are learned, as part of the
process of training this model,
incorporate really useful
abstractions related
to image classification
that transfer
to things that the original
model wasn't actually
trained on.
So you can essentially take an
already trained model and tap
into it at the so-called
bottleneck layer--
a layer of embedding just
before the output of the model--
and use that to bootstrap
training of new image
classifications.
So you can take a
neural net that's
trained on a bunch of things
like different animals
and boats and cars
and things like that,
and you can train
it on a new data
set, your own data,
new classifications,
very successfully, without
needing very much data.
So that's transfer learning.
MELANIE WARRICK: So with our
previous Cloud Vision API,
people were able to
use it for problems,
but a lot of times
their image analysis.
But they were limited to what's
provided in that Cloud Vision
API?
There wasn't as much flexibility
for their specific data sets.
Is that what I'm understanding?
AMY UNRUH: Yeah that's correct.
So the Vision API has a
fixed set of categories
that it recognizes.
A very large number
of categories,
but they're still
fixed categories.
So if you're in a
specialized domain,
it's not going to distinguish
your own domain-specific
categories the way that
you would like it to.
MARK MANDEL: I was going to
ask, what sort of categories
would you be talking about
then, that you think are,
quote unquote, "specialized"?
What does that mean?
AMY UNRUH: Well, one
really good example,
one of the early customers
is using AutoML Vision
to try to do
specialized training
of large number of different
wildlife categories.
So this is something
that AutoML Vision is not
going to be able to detect with
the right level of specificity.
SARA ROBINSON: Another
possible example
is, let's say you work in
the manufacturing industry,
and you've got very
specific parts that you're
using on some sort
of assembly line,
and you want to
determine whether there's
a faulty part in some
sort of the process.
So likely you have a
lot of training data,
images of different parts
of this assembly line.
You could train a custom model
to identify a broken part.
MELANIE WARRICK: And that's
with the AutoML Vision that's
been released as of today.
SARA ROBINSON: Yeah, so when
we would speak about the Vision
API before, the first
question we would always get
is, how can I make
this more customized?
Until today, we didn't
have an answer for that.
So that's why we're super
excited about AutoML Vision.
MARK MANDEL: So Sara,
you said something
a little earlier that I actually
just wanted to come back to.
You said that
people could provide
both labeled and
unlabeled images.
Like, I can get what
happens with labeled images.
But if I hand somebody unlabeled
images, how does that work?
Doesn't somebody have
to provide the data
about what something is?
SARA ROBINSON: Yeah,
so this is pretty cool.
One feature of AutoML
Vision is that you
can have a team of
in-house human labelers
that will review
your instructions,
and they'll classify
your images for you.
So often people have already
labeled their data sets,
but there's some cases
where you might just
have a bunch of images
that are unlabeled.
So the way this works is you
provide a few instructions.
So for the image categories
that you're hoping the labelers
will use to label your
images, you can provide a few,
what they call,
exemplar images, to say,
this is a really good example of
whatever specific label you're
trying to provide,
and the human labelers
will work on labeling
your images accordingly.
Then you'll get a
set of labeled images
back that you can feed into
AutoML Vision for training.
MELANIE WARRICK: Oh, so
there's human labelers
who can help with this.
AMY UNRUH: And AutoML
Vision also has a nice UI.
It'll detect-- if
you give a data set,
not all of the images
in the data set
have to be already
labeled, and it'll
identify the ones for you
that aren't labeled, and has
a nice UI that lets you label
them interactively, if there
aren't a huge number of them.
MELANIE WARRICK: Kind
of touching further
on this labeling-- we were
talking a little bit about this
before.
How is this different
between AutoML Vision
and the original Cloud
Vision API for labeling?
AMY UNRUH: Cloud Vision API only
exposes the prediction aspect.
It doesn't let you provide
your own labels at all.
You give it images, and it
tells you the classifications
that it's detected.
But you cannot tune it with your
own images and your own labels.
MARK MANDEL: I was just curious
as well for the developer
point of view.
How does that look?
Is there like a special API
I need to push my images to?
Do I push it to, like,
Google Cloud Storage?
What's that flow look like?
SARA ROBINSON: Are you
talking about generating
the predictions?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, so like if
I want to provide my own images
and do my own labels,
how do I get that in?
SARA ROBINSON: There's a couple
different ways to do that.
So first, if you want to try out
your model right away once it's
been trained, you can
actually just upload
images for prediction
in the UI, and see
what predictions you get back.
But then obviously
after you do that,
you'll want to build an
app that probably queries
your newly trained model.
And to do that, you can
either use the Cloud ML Engine
prediction API or you can
use the Cloud Vision API.
So if you're already using
the Vision API in production,
and let's say you
want to switch.
You have a lot of
training data, you
want to train a model on AutoML.
You actually just have to make
a few small updates to the way
your Vision API request looks.
So instead of label
detection, you
would use custom
model detection.
And then you pass it
the ID of the model
that you just
trained, and you're
good to go generating
predictions with the Vision
API.
MARK MANDEL: Sweet.
And if I have a whole bunch
of data I want to upload,
I'm guessing I'm not going
to do that through the UI.
There's some sort of
automated pipeline for that?
SARA ROBINSON: For training?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
SARA ROBINSON: Yeah.
So you can either
upload images locally
from your computer or you
can put all of your images
in Google Cloud Storage
and then create a CSV file
with the URL of your image
and the associated label,
if you have one.
MELANIE WARRICK: And if I
have any new images after I've
got a trained model, what
would that look like for this?
AMY UNRUH: You could
iteratively add new images
to your data set.
So that works well.
And then you can just
retrain once you've
added the new images.
MELANIE WARRICK: Great.
And then you were saying it's
a graphical user interface
that's can be provided
basically on the GCP website
in the same areas they
can find the other APIs?
AMY UNRUH: Currently it's
a little more standalone
in terms of the URL.
MELANIE WARRICK: OK.
AMY UNRUH: But
it's a very nice UI
that lets you inspect
valuation results,
run online predictions,
the whole deal.
SARA ROBINSON:
Eventually it will
be part of the cloud console,
but the alpha version,
as Amy mentioned,
is a separate UI.
MARK MANDEL: OK, cool.
Sara, you said something
else in passing, too,
and I think it's probably
worth going a little deeper on,
where you're talking about once
you've got a trained model that
works in Cloud
Vision API, you're
able to access it
through the Cloud Vision
API, which is really cool.
But the second
thing you said was,
you're also able to export it
through the Cloud ML Engine.
Can you just talk a bit
about what that product is
and how that would work
for people who aren't
familiar with Cloud ML Engine?
SARA ROBINSON: Sure, yeah.
Cloud ML Engine is
a product that we
provide that lets you build your
own custom TensorFlow model.
And then you can use ML
Engine to run your model
training in the cloud,
and also to deploy
your model for serving.
And this is actually what AutoML
Vision is using under the hood.
So if you're already
using Cloud ML Engine
and you're more comfortable
with that API for generating
predictions, this
is just another way
that you can generate
predictions with AutoML.
MELANIE WARRICK: All right.
Amy, you were touching before on
the neural architecture search
technology.
There was some blog post
that was released in November
around some of the work that was
done, analysis to scale that.
Can you tell us a little
bit more about what that is
and how that's used?
AMY UNRUH: Yeah, so we'll
point to some links in the show
notes.
What's typically meant by
neural architecture search
is performing some type
of neural net-based search
of neural net
architectures that are
useful for a particular task.
And there are different
variants of this-- for example,
there's an
evolutionary approach,
and there is a reinforcement
learning-based approach.
In one type of neural
architecture search framework,
there is something
called a controller
part of the framework.
It's a recurrent neural
net and what it does is it
samples child networks with
different architectures--
tries out different
architectures.
And then the accuracy
of a given child network
is used to update the
controller for its next round
of architecture generation.
One key insight is that
for image classification
problems-- for example you often
use convolutional neural nets.
They often have repeated
motifs, like for example,
different combinations of
convolutional filter banks.
And so sort of a
key observation then
is that you can build
interesting new architectures
in your search space
of new architectures
by stacking up these motifs,
these different pieces
of the neural net.
So that's technology behind
what we're using here.
AutoML is leveraging
the results of some
of this neural
architecture search
technology, and in
particular, kind
of leveraging this ability
to explore the search
space by kind of stacking
up generic cells.
So it's very interesting stuff.
And again, we'll put some
links in the show notes.
MELANIE WARRICK:
And that's great.
And my understanding too
is that the nice thing
is that this type of
approach is allowing
us to then do AutoML, not
require the people who
are using the tool to
really have a PhD in ML,
to have to know and be an expert
in terms of building models
and tuning models.
AMY UNRUH: Exactly, yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: That's
the whole intent behind it.
AMY UNRUH: And in
fact, perhaps we
should have mentioned this
earlier when we were talking
about transfer learning.
Those who are a little more
familiar with neural nets
might have tried, for
example, to do transfer
any examples using TensorFlow.
And so if you've
tried that, you'll
know that it takes a
little bit of coding
and you have to kind
of figure out how
to plug things into each other.
So with AutoML Vision,
there's none of that.
You don't need to do any
coding yourself-- or figure out
any of that.
But you're leveraging
state-of-the-art approach kind
of in the same manner.
MELANIE WARRICK: Great.
In terms of AutoML, we've
been talking about it
as Cloud AutoML Vision.
It's focused on vision.
Is there intent, or what's
the future look like for this?
SARA ROBINSON: Yeah, so this
is just the first of the AutoML
products.
We can't talk in too much
detail about what's coming next.
MARK MANDEL: Aww.
SARA ROBINSON: I know.
It's a bummer.
There are teams
that are actively
working on other products
under this AutoML umbrella
to accomplish other common
machine learning tasks
like we already provide
in our Cloud ML APIs.
MELANIE WARRICK:
So more's coming.
I mean, this tool in particular
is playing into this whole AI
democratizing MLs,
trying to make
things easier for
people to apply ML
to their products and services.
SARA ROBINSON: Yeah, definitely.
So if you're coming from an
app developer background,
and you don't have any
machine learning experience,
this tool provides a really
easy-to-use UI for you
to be able to train
a custom model
and then just use one API
call to generate predictions
against it.
MELANIE WARRICK: So
part of the reason
why we got the two
of you together
was also because
you guys have been
doing some demos around this.
Did you want to speak a little
bit to what kind of demos
and what it's been
like using the API?
SARA ROBINSON: So,
yeah, it's been
great to be able to
try out this product
and provide feedback
before the launch.
And one demo that
I worked on is I
compiled a data set
of cloud photos,
because I thought it would
be cool and kind of funny
if I used the cloud
to recognize clouds.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
SARA ROBINSON: So
what I didn't know
before I started doing this
is that there's over 10
different types of clouds.
And they all--
MELANIE WARRICK: Only 10?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, I
would have expected more.
SARA ROBINSON: There's
definitely more.
There's like 10
high-level types.
MELANIE WARRICK: I
was going to say,
I thought clouds
were like snowflakes.
Go ahead.
SARA ROBINSON: Yeah, if there's
any meteorologists listening,
they'll probably say that
there's way, way more than 10.
But I boiled it down
to 10 categories.
And all of these
different types of clouds
obviously reveal different
things about upcoming weather
patterns.
So you can use images of clouds
to predict weather patterns.
So I wanted to see
if I could build
a model that was able to
detect different cloud types.
While doing some
research on this,
I tried out the Vision API.
So I got a couple of different
types of cloud images,
sent them to the
existing Vision API,
and the Vision API was
able to identify them
as clouds, obviously,
but it didn't really
get more specific than that.
Which is fine, I
wouldn't expect it
to be able to recognize
different types of clouds.
So what I did is I
gathered training data,
I got a bunch of different
images of all of these 10
types, and I used that to
train a model with AutoML,
and it ended up
working very well.
So now I'm able to feed an
image of a cloud to the model,
and it can tell me what
type of cloud it is.
And using that I can predict
what type of weather is coming.
And actually to do this, I
worked with a meteorologist
at Google.
His name is Rob Carver.
He was a huge help
in making sure
that I labeled these
images correctly.
Obviously I'm not
a domain expert
in identifying types of clouds.
So he was able to help both
in finding photos and labeling
them correctly.
So that was a huge help.
MELANIE WARRICK: Great.
And Amy, what about your demo?
AMY UNRUH: So I've
been experimenting
with a data set of coastline
images taken by drones.
And this is a data set
courtesy of Texas A&M
that they were nice
enough to make public.
So we'll release it
in the show notes.
So this is a data
set full of images
labeled with all sorts
of esoteric labels,
things like "exposed riprap
structures," whatever
those are.
"Sheltered scarps."
MARK MANDEL: I don't know
what that is, either.
AMY UNRUH: "Salt
brackish water marshes."
Images labeled like that.
And so I'm experimenting
with how well can I
use AutoML to be able to
correctly label usage images.
And I should add something
we haven't really
talked very much about--
the AutoML UI has
a really nice interface for
inspecting what kind of results
you got from your
training-- things
like area under the
curve, precision recall
metrics, the so-called
confusion matrix that
lets you see how well your
prediction did for each label.
So this has been
really helpful as I've
been experimenting with this.
And I'm finding that some of
these different coastline types
are predicted really easily,
and some not so easily.
And that would be
an indication maybe
of where you wanted to find more
data and retrain your model.
So it's been really
fun to play with.
Again, we'll put in
the show notes links
to this so you can
experiment with it
yourself if you want to.
MARK MANDEL: So
basically, like, to sort
of hit home that
point some more,
even if I don't have a
PhD in machine learning,
I can still work out like how
accurate my predictions are
and see where my data set may
be failing just through the web
UI that's kind of
just given to me.
AMY UNRUH: Yeah, or
maybe not failing so much
as just needing a
little more data.
There's really nice
visuals on that, actually.
You can pick a
given label and you
can see sort of color-coded
little thumbnails, things
like the false positives,
the false negatives,
the true positives, et cetera.
So you can just sort of
scan for a given category--
again, where the categories are
things like sheltered scarps--
and see how well it's doing.
SARA ROBINSON: Yeah, one other
thing that you reminded me
about, Amy, is the
UI provides what's
called a confusion
matrix, which shows you
for each of your labels, what
percentage of your photos
were correctly
identified as that label.
So in my case, I could see that
maybe 80% of my cumulus clouds
were being correctly
identified as cumulus,
but maybe 20% of them
were being misclassified
as cumulonimbus clouds.
So then I could go back
to my training data
and see where I need
to add more images,
and what images maybe
aren't labeled correctly.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Any things that you
learned from
working with the API
that you feel like you want
to make sure when people start
to experiment, that they keep
in mind how they approach it,
how they use it?
SARA ROBINSON: One thing
that is great to remember
that we already touched
on is that you can
use the human labeling service.
I haven't tried this
out yet, but I'm really
keen to try it out
once I have a data
set that makes sense for it.
MELANIE WARRICK: So
you haven't tried
out the human labeling piece.
Amy, was there
anything else that you
thought you wanted
to make people
aware of from your experience?
AMY UNRUH: Yeah, on the topic
of labeling, one other thing
we should mention is that
AutoML Vision supports
multi-labeled data sets.
So that means that you
can have a set of images
that you have not given just
one classification label to,
but multiple
classification labels to.
So that's a really nice feature.
MARK MANDEL: Sweet.
SARA ROBINSON: Another
thing to mention
is that once you've
trained your model,
it's instantly ready in
production to handle traffic.
So it's available for serving
right away on Google Cloud
Platform.
So you don't have to worry
about provisioning any
of this infrastructure
on your own.
And it will also scale to zero.
So it's ready to handle lots
and lots of prediction requests,
and if you're not getting
any, it'll scale down to zero.
MELANIE WARRICK: That's a
really good point to make.
MARK MANDEL: Sweet.
I was going to ask the question.
So if people are
listening to this
and they're like,
this sounds amazing,
I want to play with this
now, where should they go?
What can they do to just
start playing with this thing?
AMY UNRUH: Good question, Mark.
Well, in the show notes,
we'll put a link to a form
that you can fill out
to get whitelisted.
And we were told that
the response to that
should be very quick.
We'll also provide a
link to the product page
and there is a
little intro video
that's launching today to give
you an overview of the product.
So we'll link to that in
the show notes as well.
MELANIE WARRICK:
So people do need
to be whitelisted in order to
access it as a starting point?
AMY UNRUH: Yeah, during
the alpha, that's correct.
But again, we were told that the
response would be very quick.
MELANIE WARRICK: Great,
well, anything else
that you wanted to share with
those listening about AutoML?
SARA ROBINSON: Nothing for me.
I think we covered it all.
AMY UNRUH: Nothing
comes to mind.
We're very excited about it.
It's super useful and
really easy to use.
MELANIE WARRICK: Great.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
SARA ROBINSON: For
people that try it
out and have any feedback, we'd
love to hear what you think.
So we'll have our Twitter
handles in the show notes.
It's a great way to give
us feedback on the product,
and we'll make sure it gets
back to the product team.
MARK MANDEL: Are either of you
speaking about AutoML any time
soon?
Can people come find you?
AMY UNRUH: If you're
local to the Seattle area,
and you're thinking to go to
conference called AI Next Con,
I will be giving a talk
about AutoML the day
after we expect this
podcast to come out.
So please look me up and
say hi if you're there.
SARA ROBINSON: And
I'm going to be
speaking about AutoML at Dubfest
Minneapolis on February 10.
So if you're going
to be at that event,
if you feel like braving
the cold to come,
it's a great event.
I've been the past two years.
Come and say hi, and
learn more about AutoML.
MELANIE WARRICK: Great,
well thank you both again
for joining us and telling
us about Cloud AutoML Vision.
And I hope you guys have
a good rest of your day.
SARA ROBINSON:
Thanks for having us.
AMY UNRUH: Thank you.
MARK MANDEL: See you.
MELANIE WARRICK: OK,
well, that was great.
Thanks, Amy and Sara.
We appreciate the
overview of AutoML.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
that's really cool tech,
especially as someone who is
definitely not in the machine
learning spectrum, being able
to use these kind of tools
to basically train and influence
how models work without having
to do all that research is
really, really impressive.
MELANIE WARRICK: Agreed.
It's where things are going.
So it's nice to see where
it is with Cloud Vision
and then to think
about where it's
going to be going from there.
So question of the week.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, so--
question of this week
is, if I'm a student,
or say I work for an
academic institution
such as a university, and I want
to be able to use Google Cloud
Platform, but ideally
not pay for it,
how do I go about getting
some credits to enable
me to basically learn how to
use Google Cloud Platform?
MELANIE WARRICK: So we
have education grants
and we are providing
a link, of course,
as always in our blog post.
And so students and faculties
can apply at this link.
And actually I think it's
more specifically for faculty
to apply and then they can
give access for students.
But apparently we have
two different approaches
for those who are in
the US versus those
who are international.
And they provide the
eligibility on the site.
They're usually looking
for universities
that are regionally
accredited or have
some level of accreditation
for those specifically
teaching computer science
or something related.
So we'll definitely provide that
information and you can apply,
you can get credits, you
can play around with this
to do research at
an academic level.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
I'm just having
a look-- last time
I looked at this,
there wasn't
international support.
So this is actually really cool.
There's a list of--
looks like about 30-odd
different countries
that are available.
But if you are a country or
an institution that is not
part of the countries
that are currently listed,
please do express interest.
That is something
that we look at so
that we can look to expand
the program in the future.
MELANIE WARRICK: Great.
Well, Mark, are you
going to be anywhere
in the next few weeks
or next couple months?
MARK MANDEL: Really
all I'm doing right now
is preparing for Game
Developers Conference in March.
So everything is
focused towards that.
How about yourself?
Are you going anywhere?
MELANIE WARRICK: I am.
I'm going to be in London at
the end of the month speaking
at AI Congress.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, fun.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Looking forward to that.
Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
All right.
Well, Melanie, thank you
very much for joining me
for yet another
episode of the podcast.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Episode 2 of 2018.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
And we'll see you all next week.
MELANIE WARRICK:
See you next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]